côté jeunes toi non pas oui et toi tu as
quel âge moi je vais là jusqu'à vers un
beau n'avoir en écrire le bateau ivre ah
bon alors tu as tu à 9 ans falah mais là
bas c'est bien c'est toi t'as quel âge
bon bah ouais pareil en train de born
this way est un peu fatigué zuma est
aussi la leur prestige et moi ça vu les
serbes que tu fais non mais ça c'est
parce que hier avant de me coucher je
j'ai fait un petit peu de lecture j'ai
relu les rougon-macquart d'un bolide
aurait fallu déjà si si si si vous avez
déjà lu mais là c'était la traduction
rust away et je connaissais pas le
russie est grave
tu avais vu en effet droid m'empêcher
appris hier soir mais ya en ce moment
qu'est ce qui fait au bois en ce moment
je continue mes études à la sorbonne
ah ben oui y'a la sorbonne jouer c'est
bien aux battues c'est donner des cours
devant 300 élèves ce point évident même
quand on est sûr doyen way du corta
maman vient de chercher à fin des
courses et la route à haute voix enfin
je lui donne la main quand même c'est
dur d'être surdoué comme vous dites oui
mais toi on s'est rendu compte quand que
tu étais surdoué
enfin moi c'est à la naissance - ah bon
mais à l'échelon mais j'étais prématurée
ah bon alors on m'a mis dans une
couveuse oui à la couveuse est tombé en
panne
ah bon
mais alors je vais réparer
là donc on est partout comment ils ont
fait descendre ben moi c'est quand j'ai
fait la visite avec les psychologues
huawei oui j'ai des têtes
oui j'ai fait les tests des bennes
demain il a tapé une dépression nerveuse
depuis les deux autres ils se sont
recyclés garde des moutons en ardèche
assez dur mon passage c'est parce que
moi je suis un cadre est troublant oui
mais je suis quand même troublant aussi
un nom je suis un code très troublant
plus troublant que toi il fait plus
troublant que toi moi je suis plus trop
bien que toi moi marabout bout de
ficelle celluloïd idéologie gymnase
office fiche de l'hymne line renaud
perdu mais oui les conneries à la télé
que j'en bave oui mais ça c'est parce
que tu regardes trop souvent la
télévision wesh
bon allez maintenant c'est terminé mais
faussetés manette wii pour le père noël
mais dis donc tu crois qu'on est pas un
petit peu en retard pour le père noël
ont battu soit on est déjà en avance sur
notre avait alors dévoilé moyenne
qu'est-ce que tu as comme en des toits
pour le père noël alors moi j'ai
commandé une panoplie de zorro panoplie
de zorro
oui en prison disent ah bon
et toi et ben moi j'ai commandé un
microscope à rayons laser pour l'étude
des mouvements sinusoïdaux en milieu
aquatique
eh bien oui oui mais j'ai pris aussi un
nounours en peluche
oui mais bon pourquoi pas pour rassurer
mes parents parce qu'ils s'inquiètent
chers amis il vient dans le cadre de
notre rubrique soit belle mais ne t'ai
pas nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
une future candidate à l'élection de
miss france qui défendra les couleurs de
sa région puisqu'elle vient d'être élue
miss alsace j'ai nommé mademoiselle
analyse j'ai nommé miss alsace centrale
sa cb
bon
rapport à ça va vous vous appelez tu
veux savoir monde
oui analyse people et ce qui est unique
à chaque fois ça évoque l'amour alors un
délice vite vous permettez que je vous
appelle à neulise envoyant un problème à
travers comme tu veux alice comment
devient ton miss alsace parlez nous un
peu de vous vous voyez d'accord je te
parle de moi non non de vous oui
d'accord oui alors si tu veux je suis né
dans le périgord
alors à la sottise huit ans je suis
arrivé en alsace est à dire il ya six
mois enfin je me suis très bien adapté
quoi prévient il alors bon et alors
alors un jour j'étais dans le bureau
avec un collègue
la collecte de bus roulent non dans le
bureau ovale d'un collègue et alors je
discute avec elle alors andy gray
analyste
tu sais pas quoi ce que je vais faire je
vais faire le concours de miss alsace
je lis quoi toi avec ta gueule tu vas
faire le concours de miss alsace et
gossip toi et ta gueule du fait
qu'aujourd'hui ça ça soit je peux le
faire aussi
allah dit si toi tu fais moi je le fais
pas alors elle l'a pas fait au plan dans
les nouveaux nuit c'est un petit peu de
votre région de l'alsace
oui par exemple à leur écoute ça c'est
vachement important il faut le savoir il
faut que la france entière le sache
l'alsace premièrement et avant tout
c'est vachement beau ensuite
deuxièmement dans l'alsace il ya du
soleil dans la journée et à la pluie
aussi à le brouillard s'est un peu
mélangé quoi alors il ya un neige dans
l'hiver il ya les sympas qui embaume qui
embellissent la région quoi il ya les
ruisseaux qui cafouille ya là
la cathédrale qui fait tilt dans des
incendies dans sa variante ça va bien on
a hâte en temps je suis laissé dire que
l'alsace est une région très vallonné ah
oui c'est très vallonné à ça c'est très
bas l'eau n'est aussi yahia le ballon
d'alsace ya le ballon de guebwiller et
je ma belle-mère ya un ballon d'oxygène
et se sont pas très bien où vous n'avez
jamais eu de problèmes avec vos
compatriotes à écoute c'est marrant tu
me pose cette question parce qu'il m'est
arrivé une mésaventure à ses
mésaventures heureuse si tu veux je vais
te raconter une fois
bon alors tu vois je tombe dans l'eau
alors je suis en train de me le noyer
alors comme toutes les personnes qui
selon noah bas comme toutes les
personnes je crie au secours au secours
un an le tipi l'arrivée est avec
apprendre à nager au lieu d'un apport de
français
c'est très très drôle comme en attendant
ses pensées anne-lise l'élection de miss
alsace lagoon physiquement n'y avait pas
de problème j'étais très nettement au
dessus du lot mais alors pour
l'intellect alors là c'est vachement dur
hein parce que vous aviez aussi une
épreuve intellectuelle ah oui je veux
croire oui et c'était de quel niveau à
peu près au niveau baccalauréat parce
qu'il y avait des deux vinet des
charades
vous pourriez nous donner un exemple de
charade
as tu me lâches arabe bon alors attends
je me rappelle à leur écoute y avait
celle là mon premier c'est un serpent
mon second se trouve sur les toits et
mon tour on le trouve dans un cas rage
en alsace
je ne vois pas bon à temps je vais
t'aider mon premier est un serpent
le python mon second se trouve sur les
toits la tuile montrent où se trouve
dans les garages en alsace le pit en
tuiles
je vois que vous applaudir pour avoir
et j'en ai des pires que ça mais je les
garde pour une autre leçon ça ne presse
pas et bien si vous voulez vivre
nous allons maintenant terminé
l'interview avec des questions dans
l'ordre peut-être plus générale d'abord
une question qui me brûle les lèvres
c'est en a pris comment faites vous pour
garder une ligne si parfaite à
jean-marie à la règle c'est pas
difficile je vois de la vierge d'un
régime de choucroute sens elle est
maintenant une lise une question plus
indiscrètes
je t'en prie aussi anne lise vous avez
déjà connu le grand frisson
ah non le grand amphi son charme et j'ai
connu le petit chaussettes dans le vide
relisez bien avant de vous quitter nous
allons vous souhaiter bonne chance pour
votre future élection oui tout au moins
nous l'espérons à miss france et puis
peut-être à nice europe et puis voir
peut-être un miss monde ou miss univers
a et maintenant qu'allez vous faire
bon je vais aller faire la mise de
minuit très joli mais d'auteur bravo et
permettez moi de vous faire la bise ma
petite anne lise camara non mais ho et
n'a pas gardé les cigognes ensemble
sept plus vieux métier du monde c'était
une profit du faubourg qui avait grandi
dans la rue re n'avait jamais connu
l'amour on l'appelait lui
un jour au coeur paris rencontre à julos
c'était la ruée saint denis le plus fier
macro il lui dit si tu veux gagner ton
pain ma vieille faut que tu ailles au
turbin
c'était une profit du faubourg à qui
avait grandi dans la rue on n'avait
jamais connu l'amour on l'appelait le
lui mais bien vite eu le béguin pour
gillot mais bien vite eu de lui un joli
marmots et pour la première fois eu
quelques instants de joie juloux
apprenons la nouvelle couru lui chercher
querelle trouva le bébé si bosh qu'il
sorti un couteau de sa poche
lulu rapidement déjà son joli rouge ton
reçu à sa place le coup dans le bras
dans la camp dans le bras
mais le couteau était bien long et
transperça le poupon julos enfuis quand
la police intervient lulu et est
immobile dans un chagrin profond
elle expliqua les faits mais ils étaient
près de 20
et on l'a trahi la en prison et oui
mesdames c'est comme ça la vie
plus tard au palais de justice on la
juge à julos déguisés en femmes contre
elle témoigna et on l'a cru
et la pauvre parisienne fut livrée à
cayenne
c'était une profite qu avait grandi dans
la rue n'avait jamais connu l'amour rond
la pole est on est le cas c'est des
pierres toute la journée le soir et le
relais son ancien métier
quand un jour bien l'heureux elle
rencontra félix un gentil braves petits
gars bien qu'il fût communiste
ils décidèrent ensemble de se marier
mais avant il savait qu'il fallait
s'évader ils creusèrent tous les jours
dans la terre et quarante ans plus tard
il à tenir la mer
il vire sur un radeau un sauvage de là
bas
mais félix était un ancien judoka et en
quelques coups s'en débarrassa ils
montèrent dans l'embarcation félix oram
lulu à la direction
enfin l'ue aura un phénix à la direction
ils s'éloignaient il était libre il crie
hier si fort que leur ado chavira félix
et lulu ne sachant pas nager périr noyés
on dit qu'il montait au ciel tous les
deux ans là c'est que saint pierre les
accueillis quand ils furent arrivés il
leur donna un plan pour le paradis mais
lulu temps perdu en chemin ce père dit
elle perdu de vue son partenaire et alla
tout droit en enfer s'étaient unis
profite du faubourg qui avait grandi
dans la rue york avait jamais connu
l'amour ont la peau l'élu
les oiseaux dans les branches en la
voyant pleurer entre les larmes en ce du
14 juillet
mesdemoiselles messieurs nous avons le
plaisir et l'honneur d'accueillir sur
notre plateau un des plus grands
virtuoses de la moule est un un des
grands maîtres de l'art tauromachique
moderne
j'ai nommé le grand torero el jambières
bonjour l on dire allez on se devait de
la scène on vous appelle l option viejo
tiens vous êtes le seul torero d'issy
les moulineaux chez et un sweat-shirt
allez et comment vous est venue cette
vocation n'est pas comment vous pouvez
parler en français marcel erice d'accord
alors je rappelle donc marcel janvier
je suis né dans prenez du négrier chez
les moulineaux et sur lesquels était
petit dont j'allais en vacances chez mon
père ma mère elle a en espagne n'ont ni
les délais de la pelouse si vous avez un
cochon est alors que j'aurai un cochon
ou alors moi sur les jus de l'été
départementaux sur la tête pour faire
une corde 1 et le soir quand ils
emmêlent joli piqué les fesses elle est
élue à tricoter de même ce qui est en
quelque sorte la préfiguration de la
pose des banderilles dans le plus pur
style au nord dans les fesses vous
oublie alors si vous voulez donc calé
noël comme j'avais eu une bonne note en
quêté schiste bombay m'a permis de tuer
le cochon mois de mars que j'ai donc
faire une captation de bac 5 par 5 ans
aucun clou rouillé au bout
quand j'ai mis trois heures à la
descente mais je vais lui la salle
et l'ours et c'est la victoire de
l'homme sur la bête que vous avez
concrétiser ce jour là qui a été pour
vous la révélation voiture volée en fait
c'est plutôt les boyaux à l'air les
tripes qui sentait monnaie est le sang
qui plus est tard d'eau et alors là je
me suis dit marcel tu seras terre adore
pardon toréador j'arrive je t'aurais
labs est allé vous former en espagne non
c'est à dire il faut dire géré par une
solide formation de tony tripier ce qui
va quand même bien l'aider dans vos
métiers y alors après ça a été le grand
voyage vers le sud
oui c'est ça vers le sud de la seine où
est donc passé un an à boulanger fait
des premières corridas d'appartements
avec des lapins
et oui puisque malheureusement un décret
d'application inique le décret 14 78 de
la loi du 14 juillet 1946 prend libre
nord de la loire la pratique de l'art
tauromachique
et alors après je suis donc descendu
vers le sud en espagne et non dans le
périgord où j'ai fait mes premières
corridas à l'air libre à elles des joies
pas trop dur is war wes d'ailleurs géré
corps et mon marteau
l'épinard enfin cette rencontre avec le
corps de baisse
mais dites moi elle tant mieux la lutte
que vous menez contre ces bêtes seul
dans l'arène
c'est un petit peu une lutte contre
vous-même congestion des showcases thuan
ce beau brun est ce que vous avez eu
peur la première fois que vous êtes
trouvé seul en face d'un vrai taureau
bas c'est à dire je voulais quand on est
habitué à la volage bon enfin ça ça
change c'est sûr ça y'a pas de problème
le gabarit n'est pas le même si vous
voulez j'ai davantage c'est que le
taureau ils veulent pas à ce qui fait qu
on prêtera de plus facile quand on y
connaît dessus sans problème c'est
comment vous n'avez pas d'épée c'est à
dire j'en avais prêté dans mon beau
frère qui est bouché la ram et de leur
prouver ce qu'on associe libre échange
et pu récupérer son tranchoir du japon
alors justement à ce propos elle
giampiero je voulais vous poser la
question qui brûle les lèvres de tous
les aficionados de la route bretagne et
basse-normandie en particulier comment
avez vous fait pour révolutionner à ce
point l'art tauromachique
on vous a vu encore récemment je crois
c'est dimanche dernier au zoo de
vincennes où vous avez tord est un
pingouin
il ne faut pas être man show
ouais c'est vrai aussi trois marques
techniques
quand on travaille à peindre dis pas tu
aurais n'est pas un bruit
suis-je bête comme on n'y avait pas
pensé plus tôt ça m'est sorti de l'idée
c'est complètement absurde
ce n'est pas trop difficile de torts et
un pingouin pas de pad minella toro ne
pas miner c'est pour ça que je me suis
formel seaway sur lavage et surtout
alors si vous voulez le parloir en fait
si vous voulez rire semble à la volaille
à cause qu'il a si vous voulez des
plumes et des palmes pareil mais il
ressemble au taureau à cause de recul
est de la même couleur souley pour le
pingouin je me suis laissé dire elles
sont guère ou que vous n'utilisiez pas
défendre et traditionnelle non non je
balance de fer à repasser multicolores
le jumeau lancé sur la gueule puisque
aussi bien que l janvier rond dans les
corridas traditionnel le torero qui a
fait une belle corrida se voit attribuer
en récompense les oreilles et la queue
mais vous lorsque vous avez bien pinguin
et qu'est-ce que vous recevez bah le
croupion il reste six ans reste comment
ça les restes oui parce que si les
banques ont jeanne termina par un noir
et que le tranchoir la faille que je
vais bien me lancer des fleurs à presser
sur la gueule je voulais la respecte à
grand chose
alors bon et je récupère tout ça dans un
sac plastique que ça ne m'aurait pas du
soir
une dernière question et ce sera notre
conclusion elle tombe hierro la corrida
un exemple pour la jeunesse
je veux parce que dans tous les bons
amis bon en ce moment est voué à
l'époque qu'on ait ça va mal de partout
à pour tuer les gènes chez lui la bête
ils veulent plus travailler ils ont plus
d'idéal et moi ce que je voulais leur
montrer aux jeunes parce que je voudrais
leur dire c'est qu'ils achats m
déshonneur à l'écraser a plus fait que
soi allez merci
saviez-vous les corps pour faire le
boulot je me suis trouvé de la la et
c'est bien meilleur à droite la forêt
des plots jusqu'au congo mais moi j'aime
bien prendre
mieux même la forêt n'est plus vierge
qu'est ce que c'est assez a fort à faire
pour essayer pour le quotidien
alors les filles
comment tu t'appelles toi et toi comment
tu t'appelles je vous appellerai eh bien
non
les filles si vous voulez durable monté
sur moi
de l'autre jour s est cassé
qu'est ce que c'est ça pascal compotier
de noël
et
c'est pas peur de ça je me dis lui qu'à
chaque fois il fait divers éléphants ils
seront mêlées se mettront-ils n'a rien
pour sa défense on est pile mais dors tu
as une visite est trop grande astuce on
fait l'amour
les gars du déficit
c'est quoi ça ça c'est un accueil manque
à manger une chèvre memory le fromage
aux caïmans non plus les enfants
qui vient de dieu
suivez sur une belle île dans une petite
cabane déjà toute petite fille je
mangeais des grosses bananes grosse
banane je suis vraiment la nana y en a
pas deux comme moi il paraît qu'à panama
toutes les filles ont le cuba le cubain
d'un témoin vie comme il faut un oui
mais j'ai un gros défaut je veux à nos
pieds du fric je m'en fous qui soit beau
je suis une négresse afrique
oui elle a un grand défaut elle va donc
elle s'en foutent les soirs c'est une
église a pris ici vous voyez mon grand
père ses deux mois tout le contraire on
dirait un vrai zombie
il a la tête haïti a quitté d'empathie
le billet a été le monstre la gauche
bête qui monte
oui ait pas de maison
si vous voyez ma copine complique et du
soir au matin elle danse très mal at il
dit
on dirait avait boudé les bouteilles à
vous de vous décrire ce thème au menu
comme une fois tout alors oui mais j'ai
un gros défaut
jma dans qui est du coup en coupe
soisbault je suis une décollecte a pris
soin à les pousse à les pousser pas
pourquoi ni mon frère ou alors voir
quel est le fruit je préfère tour on ne
sait pas quel est le fruit je préfère
toutefois ne sais pas quel flic je
préfère toujours en eux ces bacs qu'elle
ne lui veux tu prévient je donne ma main
gauche à qui elle dit oui je m'en fous
qu'il soit pro je suis une étape
attendez l'époque où on les attendait ya
thierry le luron
il a plein de pognon iossif et émouvant
il a plein de dollars
les verts et aux fines on va danser à
m'écrire un becquet à l'ère d'internet
indiqué
ouais
d
m
vous allez allez
on était partis pour les vacances en
afrique on s'est retrouvé les tours et
sur l'antarctique
on avait la fina billets juste nasri
pour le cap des 11 et mise en smoking et
ils on l'a filmé de dos penguins
faut vous dire si c'était pas évident
les eskimos sont froids et nous on
claque des dents on ad'abord sympathisé
avec l'ours blanc mais c'était pas
facile il fallait freiner ses élans et
si ça vous arrange
je vous présente un manchot c'est pour
vous ces leggings et google est plus
serré afin qu'ils parlent will ça fait
trois causes l'est c'est pour vous c'est
qui c'est vous dire est préféré à 20 khz
et de ballerines ça va être à gonfler
ses deux skis beau les nuits de blizzard
on organise des soirées pardo et que ce
sont souvent des invités petit à petit
notre vie c'est bien la talent et on a
vite appris à chasser et à pêcher
à tous les repas romance détecte de
baleine c'est être attentif y en mai en
plus dans nos veines même les cieux l on
refuse de nous tirer paraît qu'à cause
de nous les routes sont défoncées
meilleur mammouth et quatre complices
c'est pour voter vieillissent et
bouriane gérer un parc et de perrine ça
fait trois causes les cvo s'est glissé
vous y réfléchirait à pas et de
ballerines savez 3,11 et les 50 les plus
chaudes eskimos dommages à mettre des
sous titres ce qui advient o'connor
c'est qu'ils connaissent pas la crise
quand on n'a pas d'argent on passe à la
banquise sur un respect pour la louer à
l'igloo meyrin qu'on a bâtie toutes les
deux de nos propres mains
le manchot la sefa qui nous a pas donné
un coup de main
pourtant depuis six mois comprend des
bas dans la glace qu'on aurait envie
d'un plongeon aux bahamas
on va lui demander de nous construire un
avion faut partir avant d'être
transformée en glace on pourquoi au
canada parce que c'est ma cabane au
canada c'est vous c'est gai qui sait
mourir est plus serré afoc et de ben oui
ça fait 3 2 les ses boubous s'est glissé
le greffe gérer un parc et de ballerines
savait pas drôle et c'est bon
dans
48 c'est lui le cerveau de passe les
carottes sont cuites
ça va ça lui doit être fait de passes
défendions quick mot de passe dans les
48h à savoir la semaine dernière
c'étaient les handicapés prochaine ce
sera quand on veut c'est ce à quoi je
sers mon fils et moi j'ai tout rockets
bien messieurs
ça fait dix ans qu'on se connaît on se
réunit tous les mois mais cette fois ci
c'est un gros coup ce coup là c'est le
bon rappelez vous il ya dix ans notre
première rencontre je t'avais convoqué
toi douanes fait parce que d'aller mal
il sait bien ouvrir les tiroirs caisses
touahri tu sais conduire une camionnette
ouais voilà toujours moi le premier
quand on fait des conseils du copain on
appelle le champion doucement rock culte
de la personnalité et le prof titre il
ya plus de diplômes à lui seul que nous
tous réunis en effet
j'ai failli réussir le certificat
d'études bien messi avant de commencer
je vous propose d'observer une minute de
silence à la mémoire de riton mort au
comptoir il ya deux jours du coup il est
mort et on était avec lui rapporte s'est
fait complètement moi je serais pas venu
c'est terrible pardon
enlève ta casquette bon la minute à
montfrin 5 parce que j'ai pas de montre
on commence tôt qu'est ce que vous ferez
comme si en 5 secondes de 6,5 secondes
de silence top 5 secondes c'est bien si
vous tous les coups qu'on a fait jusqu'à
présent c'était de l'amusé gueule
c'était de biscuits apéritifs maintenant
on va passer aux choses sérieuses vous
connaissez tous la mer goriot savait
qu'elle est une mercerie pour les
boutiques et bien ce que je veux c'est
la mercerie de la mer caen
à ces rochers dire une chose moi je sais
pas je suis pas con enfin j'ai pas sur
les épaules assez solides pour ça oui il
a raison ça trop gros pour je me retire
trop tard irritant c'est déjà trop ouais
t'as raison c'est un bon coup je reste
voilà comment ça se présente moi je
serais déjà dans la nursery à pénétrer
comment je me serais habilement
dissimulé en clients jade église et
comment pas besoin de se déguiser un
gros bonnet passe inaperçu dans une
mercerie à google
bon je voudrais poser une question sa
roue tu vas faire le client mais qu'est
ce que tu vas acheter une paire de
chaussettes une paire de chaussettes
mais mais c'est au moins chez bos france
65 je me suis renseigné seulement
j'avance l'argent investi faut se
mouiller et c'est là où la tête du
marchand de barbe à papa de l'année
dernière va nous servir
non je vous convoque dans un endroit
isolé alors fait moins de bruit bien
prof montre nous le plan c un plan paris
fait il alors la mère serait il est dans
le vaucluse cerveau je vais poser une
question ça ne te dérange pas que la
mercerie sera en face du commissariat
à quelle heure on fait des coups à 14
heures seniors là ils sont tous au troc
et google voici les instructions elles
sont scellées jour whif attention ne pas
déchirer c'est ma soeur qui les a cédées
de la confiance
jolie se découvre en même temps goût
toile toi tu fais tu viendras pied toi
viry jeu viendra avec sa camionnette
camouflet en voiture police a essayé à
les peindre c'est bon toi doit être fait
à pied prendre les périphériques toi
rire avec sa camionnette tu prends dans
les égouts attends attends ya quelque
chose qui me gêne
il ya deux ans que je bute dessus
j'arrive pas savoir ce que c'est
reprends toi tu dois te faire pieds tu
prends les périphériques touahri la
camionnette que pour les égouts attend
inverse à 2
s'inverse ça donne toi doigts de fée à
pied tu prends les égouttoir irin avec
la camionnette tu prends le périphérique
je continue à 14h05 précise le cerveau
pénètre la mer goriot de la mercerie
j'ai voulu faire comme toi j'ai voulu
inverser
hambourg - mois à 14h05 précise le
cerveau achètent des chaussettes qui
veut mettre cinq minutes si je veux dire
tout autant que moi bien faire maquiller
de poids ça fait dix ans que je voudrais
que la mère gorille aux matchs et dakota
à 14h10 je le rejoins à 14h15 précis toi
toi tu fais tu sors de la plaque d'égout
emplettes cuisine
ouais tu fonces derrière le comptoir des
mers cordiaux il ya un coffre oui
attends je t'arrête quelques jours de
cow boy de chaussures quelques voitures
42g combien de temps une minute temps
bien élastique
oui je demande deux minutes accorder
l'attention élastique tout cas pas là
quand même
à 14h16 précis toi very high tech à
mener mais moi j'arrive dans la version
jose pile on prend le coffre-fort montée
on se bat l'accompagnement ce qui est
super je nous vois tous les quatre dans
des camionnettes remarques des polices
bo elle jean mimi 2 pour sa phase bien
ils désespèrent à la campagne à la mer
en valeur en des vacances non mais
qu'est ce que tu as écrit sur les
camionnettes et au deuxième
mois prochain ses dix ans de travail
n'ont rien
j'avais entendu la mienne excusez moi je
comprends mal à trouver mes numéros soit
et les billets sont produites par
cécilia dans mon mari si fatigué pour
moi parce qu'on prend 1,50 chômage c'est
crevant c'est aussi dans cette famille
apparemment pas les enfants du mackenzie
dernier il m'a fait la coqueluche tout à
lui jean pierre à bot est impossible de
leur noble avec retard à new york elle a
fait long feu et vit la hausse avec mon
mari on a fait hier chez les flics
tellement fait du tapage dans le midi
bonjour et bienvenue sur mon mari les
flics il n'a pas osé dérangé c'est comme
un aveugle
trois enfants vous savez ce qu'elle fait
non dites moi tour et monsieur vous dire
elle regarde le ciné club tu sais des
mines les mine upa sur et tous en vo van
soit pas mal de l'intrus polar en bo1
version autochtones
elle est normale aux calomnies dix sept
elle comprend avec celui en français en
plus elle regarde des films on
autochtones alors c'est bon si ce n'est
un genre très simplement
vous avez vu résultats comme moi il
endort du matin sur les sont pas ouverts
si c'est pas malheureux de voir se fera
surtout pour une femme
ah oui vous savez c'est facile des gens
qu'on pas d'horaires parce que je vous
dis à moi le dimanche
parfois ils déjeunent à des mini passé
parfois unis c'est pas nous qui vous
avons réveillé une conversation suspect
on s'est donné on essaie shit en train
de se faire de soucis là elle doit être
malade pour moi la musique est la
première saison l'an passé dont j'étais
en course
à quand il fait beau brun d'octobre le
losc d'affiché comme ça point d'octobre
à paris
ils n'ont annoncé à tous même si vous
deviez coûté à 6 m ils n'y ont même
annoncé la télé hier soir susurré à
manier la batterie de questions qui sont
des eaux
c'est pas grave la concierge a voulu
ramasser même vos corps est elle même le
pic est oui plutôt
mais oui ça y est c'est comme ça qu'elle
a monté tout rosso de sa 6éme arias
ménages
parfois tu es sur effectif qui compte
d'une fenêtre au format g8 c'est un
caleçon avec les étrennes qu'on me donne
pas comme ça cherchez-vous pika je vais
vous dire un script à dupliquer son
caleçon à vue du mineur séquestré et
tous les registres gratuit berry
céderait à côté des miens ils sont tous
grillés à côté dé voter pour vous dire
on a ici un petit matelas laisse
imaginer que l'horreur mêmes et
adoucissantes dans mail est vraiment du
centre de l'argent dépensé surtout bossé
sancerre ses draps housse est vendue au
corps et à la faillite en belgique et
elle était dans l'escalier au train de
distribuer le courrier
c'est sûr qu'elle était en train de dire
du mal de la piscine vide et 5e 6 a même
fait un dernier set qui prend la pilule
et prend la pilule est amère mais ont
rapidement accusé retrouvé des
plaquettes peter hill nouvelles communes
de l'immeuble il est attendu chez les
soeurs c'est plus sympa
ne cherchez pas wolf au stade ivor wynne
comme un petit fou faudrait pas venir
mais la lellouche plutôt que quand il
fait des claquettes vide
elle serait bienvenu dans cette
cathédrale de la ville
enfin vous demandez comment et c'est
parce qu'il m'a dit matt pokora tel
succès mais là où c'est pas vrai les
gazelles avant nous le dira nous sommes
malheureusement comme concierge qui
parle dans steam et vinci dans le rang
comme en dernier
vous savez moi je trouve ça incroyable
cet enfant est un mari chômeur au
chômage
mais mais ça je veux dire que tu as un
tel fait des chômeurs je vous respecte
et ma musique
il avait réveillé quand ils ont parlé
m'a occupé bas faut bien qu'ils se
frottent chose m'a pris et mailly fo
c'est vous dire matrix personnellement
moi j'aurais pas supporté marie son
beurre avec votre mari a pas briscard
mais son métier ça une position bien
star abbas un représentant bretelles ses
stars ça fera des pantalons la bretelle
à vous l'avez dit maquereau a affaire à
des pantalons il ya enfin droite elle
commence à se fatiguer pas eu d'enfants
gbagbo marie jo sur les routes on n'a
pas le temps or je suis bête du maïs et
6 passes et marqué d'un sens ça c'est
pas plus mal parce que c'est vrai
regardez les mêmes lellouche l'iphone et
des cinq six enfants passaient là et par
finalement ils n'ont pas le temps de
s'en occuper
je peux vous dire quelque chose même
lellouche elle les accompagne pas les
toits seymour
mais il sait pas pourquoi je le sens
pourquoi n'y aurait aucun dernière fois
qu'elle a accompagné cet enfant nicole
sinon confronté le regarder c'était
toute une histoire
il enclenche la récréation ils l'ont
relâché quatre la rabine excuse pour mam
lellouche quand même alan bond de 7,6 à
main c'est vrai le mariage gay incident
remonte à me les dix fois plus dans le
tennis ou dix fois moins trois nouvelles
bamba prescillia ne faisait pas peur
gilmar trouver le faire et demi doit
maintenant plus à 11 ans faisant le
ménage ou des participations les amis
plus attendre avril à la salle au cinéma
c'est pour énerver les cinémas
franchement allociné mono sélection en
reste face à calais au cinéma et vous et
moi me suis trop fou m'arriver l'erreur
du cinéma l'on n'y va jamais au cinéma
je vous dire d'abord qu'on y va on fait
des 25 26 francs passé soit plus la
dernière fois que j'y étais j'ai raté le
dernier métro n'a jamais images mais
pardonner à basse-terre et perez de
malte rufo mais moi je vais vous dire
une chose je préfère regarder cinéma a
three lions
mais on est bien content mais je me fais
un petit plateau repas oui du poulet je
mange des loups la cuisse à main
contenant mais j'ai pas trop si bien on
me dit moi je vais vous dire mon mari il
y va tout seul parce que tu es un homme
et une femme c'est pas donné mais
l'ancien messin
je vous raconte
c'est mon cadeau d'anniversaire derrière
mon mari si vous iranien 800 plants et
excitante m monsieur vous dire ma
belle-mère et pas très bien portants
alors si jamais ça veut sourire on ne
pas te papa tivat midi la france jérôme
anger pour les styles a eu beaucoup de
l'école nous élisons peu mieux mais
gardez la cantine des personnes par jour
attendus par tous les hivers au spvq a
fait l'erreur de manière légitime nous
mais il faut lui l'est pas pour dire
mais je préfère pas avoir d'enfant
qu'avoir des sous doués comme elles
entrent ils peuvent même pas manger tout
seul vitaux même s'il est mal edith et
marcel il en voudrait jamais robin c'est
sûr c'est sûr en plus si vous saviez le
tapage qui font de week-end ainsi bruit
assez brute malouda mais vous savez
qu'on va être tranquille dimanche qui
vous pique [ __ ] au salon du bricolage
ben alors mon mec tranquille alors
vivement dimanche servirait de mépris
pour aller
et là mademoiselle messieurs ils étaient
24 avant de partir aux états unis au
retour de leur tournée des états unis
sous le plus grand chapiteau du monde
ils n'étaient plus que dix huit
tellement leur numéro était périlleux
après un séjour sous le grand cirque de
moscou
ils se retrouvaient seulement à 12
ensuite après une tournée de nouveau sur
le continent américain en amérique
latine
ils se retrouvaient à 8 après un séjour
en afrique et en europe centrale
ils étaient six puis quatre ce sont les
frères ni l'os
je vous demande de bien vouloir les
applaudir ils sont là ce soir 30
et voici le premier des nuls hausse
voici porto
ribaux
passé
rideau
non
ouais
quatre frères
il a fallu que le prg en fer tiennent en
est assez petit fils
voici le vieil l'ancêtre archibald
d'autres dénoncent l amazone messieurs
le premier numéro qui va être réalisée
devant vous est le numéro qui a créé
connaître les du losc dans le monde
entier
ce numéro il consiste en une cascade
extrêmement dangereuse ils ont appelé
eux mêmes le byzance
ouais ouais ouais ouais
hop
vous avez ici assisté world offre en
quelque sorte puisque maintenant nous ne
semble pourtant pas encore au plat de
résistance le deuxième numéro qui va
être réalisée devant vous va exiger de
votre part une attention soutenue
en effet c'est un véritable numéro
fabuleux qui va suivre qui se fait au
moyen d'une chaise à partir de laquelle
ils vont élaborer une des plus
originales et plus fameuses pyramides
dans le monde
voici dans leur nouveau numéro les
nullos ça s'appelle la pyramide hausse
ouais
bach
monsieur j'attire maintenant votre
attention sur le fait suivant le porteur
rico le porto rico bas grâce à sa sangle
abdominale en mer de boeuf faire de vous
un numéro de porter absolument
époustouflant il va au moyen d'une alter
invisible porter sur ses épaules deux de
ses frères
la sangle et en mer de boeuf nous et là
on pêche pour tous d'avoir une boîte
ouais ouais ouais
ce numéro est suffisamment difficile à
réaliser et la moindre erreur pouvait
être fatale à porto rico
voici maintenant un numéro qui les a
fait connaître en chine où ils ont
exécuté pour la première fois au monde
sur la pyramide de chine
ce numéro s'appelle et polo s'il est
extrêmement dangereux puisqu'il est
constitué de plusieurs escalade surmonté
d'une double pirouette salto avant sur
l'épaule gauche du double porter qui est
à la base
ouais
bah
priseur ils sont à cran battre ils sont
funambule ils sont véliplanchiste mais
ils sont aussi une formation d'andy
pauliste c'est maintenant à un saut un
terribles sautes sur blanche que nous
allons voir ce numéro suivant qui
s'appelle le béret tos bastos je vous
demande mesdames et messieurs là encore
la plus grande attention car ce numéro
nécessite de la part des protagonistes
une concentration plus que horwill
à lagos ouais ouais ouais
ouais sont des choses qui arrivent eux
j'ai bio qui est le plus vieux nullos
pas réussi à se maintenir sur la chaise
porteuse mais il y aura beaucoup de
courage il l'a prouvé
car il a quand même fait au dews aussi
pour le préciser
les ai dit on va vous montrer encore une
fois qu'il est le vétéran et qu'il a le
plus d'expérience en exécutant un salto
morteau ce qu'il est seul au monde à
pouvoir exécuter et qu'il est le seul à
avoir réalisé jusqu'ici sans la moindre
égratignure 11 et bio c'est à vous tous
vos petits fils vous regarde et aussi
tous les spectateurs du cirque
ouais
e
le numéro aurait réussi bravo chaleureux
applaudissements
bonsoir magdane bon sens mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur
alors oui alors gars à moi je te cultive
oui je sais ce que c'est qu'une pièce de
molière maintenant ah oui c'est vraiment
bien je suis content que tu vas prennent
tous ah oui et puis j'ai pavage aimerait
bien rencontrer l'auteur qui révèle
comme s'il avait le temps de te recevoir
en prime time et j'ai jamais rien vu
d'aussi chiant même les comédiens son
plateau ils sont endormis au mieux tu
rigoles non attends tu peux me rappeler
le titre de la pièce là qu'on vient de
voir la belle au bois dormant pour ben
may fabien cette pièce un lien je n'ai
pas très bien compris le dénouement mais
chérie c'est pas fini c'est l'entracte
ah bon il nous manquait des éléments cet
effort un jour tu es tu vas shakespeare
c'est un gars qui est qui dans son
répertoire est le seul avec othello
avoir pensé à donner des rôles aux
comédiens
hubert a su apprécier le spectacle
j'aimerais dire il faut le guitariste
avec scc khiter sur son genou et a
brandi son sexe vers le public a répondu
moi moi j'ai été conquis 1 et je ne veux
voir karajan maintenant dorénavant
qu'avec un blouson cuir une banane
c'était bien les coûts de la prochaine
fois on ira l'hôtel est aussi cher on
est allongé revancharde à écouter
s'était pas vu le vraiment fabuleux ya
bien voulu dans cette pièce vous voulez
ya une espèce de de gestuelle de
recherche de l'espace c'est fabuleux se
disent étonnés moi j'y vois une espèce
d'objective isation n'est ce pas de la
scène parallèlement à celle de l'acteur
qui revient à conflit latent du combat
sur le ca ah oui tout à fait mais il
arrive à un point de maturité étonnant
et audard repoussé si vous voulez on va
te féliciter je connais jean jacques
debout je connais parfaitement chantal
goya
je dirais franchement cette pièce là
j'ai rien compris rien rien du tout quoi
t'as rien compris la pièce va bien s'en
souvient encore j'aime bien qu'on écoute
a renvoyé le chanceux c'est évident moi
ça me parle moi moi c'est jj comprend
j'arrivais tout compris ouais c'est ici
c'est limpide
tu as compris un truc à sa toile et oui
c'est clair comme l'eau le ballon à son
nom soit sympa explique moi et tu fais
ce que gérant des moulages tu vas bien
sûr du théâtre alors qui c'est arrivé je
vais voir une pièce un homme un homme
nommé un homme nommé un homme nommé
hossein
tu veux dire j'ai passé la même chose
voire homard grèce
alors est ce vraiment je suis déçu moi
j'adore les spectacles de danse et ça
vraiment je suis déçue déçue déçue y
avait de belles filles
non mais tu comprends ce qu'a
sélectivement d'originalité tu vois le
décor est venu je vais te dire la
musique est insignifiant je dirais
danseurs on se demande où ils ont appris
à danser
tu vas me dire moi j'ai été profondément
déçu surtout la danse est profond je
suis déçu belles cuisses combative y est
allé dire le bon dieu tu le savais exit
les strapontins c'est peut-être
l'arrivée des agités super hein mais
j'ai finalement repris le tapis rouge
l'art de tapis rouge c'est le sang du
peuple sans que le pape après l'effort
edit et les feuilles qui tombent elles
et tu n'as pas compris non baisse et
décadence de la bourgeoisie c'est la
bourgeoisie qui pourront dans le fond la
sonnerie dodu la faucille et le marteau
ça j'ai pas compris
abate la voile alors dit moi il était
comment les les décors comment noms et
les décors ils étaient comme ans et non
six comme un jeu
l'entracte comme ça on va pouvoir faire
l'amour plutôt raté ses parts
ça bizarre non ça c'est déjà assez
bizarre bonjour dit libre qu'est ce que
tu as pensé de ces trois heures de
musique indienne web à ses profits n'y
sont pas encore commencé l'annoncé
terminer là un bon ben je crois qu'ils
accordaient leurs instruments rémy
s'était bien passé ah ouais c'était un
orchestre et on était dans la fosse à la
faute et toi tu étais bien placé dans
les baignoires mois plus tôt par terre
dans les cintres
vous avez de la chance les gars moi
j'étais au poulailler